[Music]
[Music]
how does it feel to have a full body of
work out there
it feels absolutely surreal it was
multiple years in the making and i don't
know i mean you know i grew up
worshiping
so many pop artists and all of their
full-length albums and so to be at a
place in my career where um you know i
was able to release a collection of 12
songs is absolutely surreal
[Music]
you have created some incredible
love self-love heartbreak songs uh and i
just want to know in your opinion what
is the best love song of all time
honestly probably
love you like i'm gonna lose you meghan
trainor i think megan's an incredible an
incredible artist an incredible writer
she's always been an inspiration of mine
um and that song just has stuck with me
ever since it's been released and their
vocals together is pure magic let's talk
about the track trevor for a second
where did that come from first of all
and does trevor
[Music]
[Music]
trevor is one of my favorite songs on
the album if not my favorite it was
originally about an actual boy named
trevor who does know about the song who
loves the song and who like sent me
flowers when the album came out like
he's a sweetheart he's an absolute
sweetheart and he absolutely knows that
the song is about him didn't work out
between us but we we are friends and we
we love friendship that's always great
[Music]
do you ever worry about getting too
vulnerable with your music
i
of course have moments in my writing
sessions where i'm like huh like are we
really about to say this is this really
happening you know i've always been able
to like wear my heart on my sleeve and
so when i'm writing music i usually find
that like my best songs
happen also because it comes from a very
vulnerable and honest conversation using
lyrics that are very true to myself
[Music]
[Music]
how does it feel to be representing
queer people with this incredible
pop music when i was younger
you know it was hard for me to look up
to and find openly queer artists
singing truly about their
everyday experiences when i write music
i want the songs to be heard by
everybody in the world but it's so so so
special to
you know talk to other queer people who
hear the music and who actually hear
themselves in the lyrics and i think for
me that that's like the biggest the
biggest reward that comes out of me for
making music
so oh hey there if you want more lgbtq
news and exclusive interviews click
subscribe or watch these videos